hey what is up guys my name is Aero and
welcome to the first episode of an
entirely new series morning coffee in
this first episode we're going to cover
class member access control or
visibility in Java in all there are four
visibility modifiers in Java public
private protected and of course default
which is no modifier at all let's take a
look at public modifying the visibility
of your fields and methods to public
will make them accessible throughout
your entire project it's pretty simple
if you define a field of method to be
public you can use it anywhere complet
completely unrestricted protected is a
little more restrictive however it's
still pretty free good programmers
utilize protected as their most freaking
modifier as is perfect for most
situations protected allows you to
access the Fielder method in the same
package as where it's defined if the
class where it's used in is a subclass
of words defined or for use in its own
class next up is the default modifier no
modifier at all this is the same as
protected minus the subass usability
using it in its own class it's not all
you can do with it however you can also
use it in any any class that is in the
same package as the class where it was
defined last of all is the most
restrictive modifier private private
only allows you to use the defined field
or method in the class where it's
defined if you make something private
it's locked to that class so why use
modifiers why not just make everything
public that's actually a good question
because making everything public
certainly doesn't have any impact on
performance the main reason is usability
if you design a method or variable to be
used in a particular class or group of
classes or in a particular way you want
to eliminate the possibility of
accidentally calling it from another
class by making it private default or
protected the compiler simply won't
launch the application if you've
referenced a field or method in a class
outside its visibility in short this
makes good coding practice particularly
in organizations and professional work
or anywhere you share code between
people visibility is extremely
important thanks for watching and I hope
you enjoyed the first episode of morning
coffee I'll be back tomorrow but until
then this has been the chero goodbye